You choose to implement this with a 32 x 32 block,
and your boss comes running into your office
excitedly one day, saying NVIDIA is shipping a new GPU,
and it has 4 times the storage per SM, 4 times the registers, and 4 times the shared memory.
You know that your blur kernel is completely bound by global memory bandwidth,
but now you know that you can run a kernel that's twice as big in both directions.
So instead of 32 x 32, now it's 64 x 64.
Express as a decimal what is the speed up of your program on this new GPU.
Speed up reflects my program will run n times faster.
Again ignore the bandwidth required for the blur kernel in the right back of v_new.